in this video I'm going to take a few
minutes to tell you about one of our
sponsors that make the David Pakman show
possible it's a fascinating new project
called Monet and you can find out more
about Monet using the link underneath
the video so Monet is a project that
wants to solve a number of different
problems in the world of blockchain and
peer-to-peer services and these problems
relate to privacy transparency security
and just the efficiency of networks and
first I just want to get everybody up to
speed about some of the background when
we say the peer-to-peer economy we're
talking about people interacting or
doing business directly with one another
without any intermediary someone sells
someone else a car without using a
dealership you send someone a file over
the internet without uploading it
anywhere there's no middleman involved
that's peer-to-peer sometimes we think
of the interactions we have on a site
like eBay as peer-to-peer because we're
buying something from another person or
you use a ride-sharing app where someone
comes and picks you up in their own
personal vehicle these are sort of
peer-to-peer in a sense but they really
aren't because there's still a
centralized intermediary that's
facilitating everything and this is
exactly the space that Monay is dealing
with their goal is to make more of our
communications with one another more of
the business we do with each other more
authentically peer-to-peer without the
need for these middlemen so why would we
want to do that is a good first question
every time we have one of these hubs in
the middle it's a company that's
probably collecting data about us how
much data and what kind of data varies
it can be confusing but it's rarely what
we want can we stop them from collecting
data often you can't if you want to use
their service and you need to use their
service because often there are not good
alternatives often these companies are
hiding things from us there are things
about their platform that they don't
want us to know secrecy that works to
their advantage think about the YouTube
algorithm often these companies are also
compromising the security of our
computers our credit cards our bank
accounts we see this all the time with
the hacks that take place and then of
course when there's someone in the
middle they're taking their cut there's
a monetary cost to the people who are
interacting because in many cases
they're having to
the service that facilitates whatever
the two people are doing which creates a
lot of waste in terms of money a lot of
these issues as Monet sees it could be
solved by having people on the internet
deal with one another in a way that
bypasses the people in the middle
altogether if it would be possible to
have more transactions in cooperation
without somebody in the middle where two
people or a group of people are just
dealing directly with one another
that's what Monet thinks would be
working more in our favor and that's
what their project is all about trying
to get us closer to and many of the
things we do obviously one type of way
that people have tried to decentralize
certain models is what we've seen with
things like Bitcoin where a public
blockchain is used a large decentralized
network that's cryptographically linked
using computers all over the world
anyone can see what's going on in the
network anyone can interact with it it
has many many nodes around the world all
working together at the same time to
keep the network running and this
network might be necessary for something
like a decentralized currency but Monet
sees the public blockchain as a flawed
solution to many of the peer-to-peer
economy needs because not every peer to
peer interaction requires such a massive
network of nodes a lot of the time you
don't need computers on different
contents continents processing your
commands the way you would need with
Bitcoin for example sometimes you just
need to be linked with one other person
or the small group of people that you're
working with the other issue is that
when you interface with a public
blockchain you're still using it
similarly to how you would use many
other centralized online services you're
counting on someone else to do your
computing and to manage your data
so here's Monet's solution here's how
Monet wants to solve the privacy
transparency and security issues of
relying on centralized third parties as
well as just the inefficiencies of
public blockchains Monet offers an
infrastructure whereby two people or a
group of people can establish small
temporary private blockchains where the
only users who are connected are the
users who need to be connected with each
other when you want to start working
with someone else the blockchain is
created
it exists only as long as the users are
wanting to be connected and then it
disappears each node of these
short-lived miniature block chains are
actually mobile devices owned by each of
the users and Monet calls these mobile
ad-hoc block chains and they're building
a free open-source software development
kit which lets developers add them own a
blockchain consensus to their
applications which allows apps to use
these mobile ad-hoc block chains and it
introduces a new paradigm quite frankly
where users can dynamically join or form
small closed off block chains just for
the duration of the transaction it
eliminates the need for servers it's
ephemeral by nature so users aren't
required to stay online to support other
users it can be much more efficient and
much more secure as a way of interacting
and Monet itself is a permanent public
blockchain which provides the
infrastructure services to users and
developers who want to be involved with
these mobile ad-hoc block chains but
Monet is not itself a centralized server
through which end-users would be sending
their communications and Monet even has
potential applications in the gaming
industry most people think of games in
the context of the centralised
client-server model but they often don't
consider the possibilities of
peer-to-peer Monet actually sees
bringing peer-to-peer to gaming as a way
to make game implementation and
maintenance cheaper for game developers
through not relying on servers and
content delivery platforms peer-to-peer
games can also be more stable in the
sense that not having to rely on servers
also means you're not worried about
servers being down which can be a big
problem in the gaming world Monet is
developing a plug-and-play peer-to-peer
solution for game developers that would
also provide a lot of what centralized
servers provide like cheating prevention
and fault tolerance Monet also sees
their mobile ad-hoc blockchains
as being suitable for the transportation
industry so I think of uber uber but
truly peer-to-peer where drivers are
able to make more profit there's not a
big company in the middle of everything
collecting everybody's data creating
other problems there could be use cases
all across the sharing economy
in fact with the potential to
decentralize housing decentralized space
rental decentralized package delivery
and the Monet protocol could be used for
peer-to-peer money lending investing
everyday payments bill sharing a lot of
other just consumer finance applications
and the decentralization could apply to
something as simple as just
communicating right chatting between
phones and in fact they've already
created an app for Android and iOS that
uses the protocol where users can chat
with each other without using any kind
of server in the middle it basically
functions as a messaging or texting app
but can provide more security and
certainly more privacy
so there's lots of different use cases
where this could be applied where a
blockchain itself is replacing what a
server had been doing but with the
benefits of disappearing out of thin air
when you're done using it so that
companies or hackers aren't able to hang
on to all of the data or your personal
information the company behind Monet is
mosaic networks they've been developing
a lot of different innovative software
solutions for years there's a lot of
work that they've been doing building up
to Monet for instance Monet uses a
protocol called Babel which is another
product of mosaic it's what allows
developers to integrate Monet into their
apps mosaic was co-founded by CEO
Giacomo Perini
who was involved in the very early days
of Bitcoin and founded a decentralized
cryptocurrency working closely with
venture capital funds around here in
Cambridge and Boston Massachusetts
Giacomo holds a master's degree in math
and Finance from Columbia mosaics chief
technology officer is Martin era vets
who I actually interviewed on the show a
few weeks ago as part of a sponsored
interview and he created the company's
first products which include babel and
he holds a degree in applied math from
the university of chicago and then you
have Ronan Lynch who's an important
member of the software development team
led a lot of the pioneering work on the
first uses of distributed Ledger's in
financial markets years ago he also has
run several high volume and
operationally complex
trading desks for Scotiabank and the
National Bank of Canada and then John
Knight is another member of the
developer team he has 20 years of
experience in software analysis design
and delivery and has spent the last four
years working for the Cambridge
University Development Trust on a really
innovative app designed to help people
teach English as a foreign language
some of mosaics advisors include MIT
lecturer Mark Stewart day tech executive
Stephanie Lynch Habib finance manager
odd B Hersey and mauro martino who's the
researcher at IBM and a professor here
in boston at Northeastern University so
this is one of the truly more impressive
teams that you see working on blockchain
projects diverse sets of experience
expertise that really culminates in what
they're accomplishing now with Monet so
I've really enjoyed following everything
that's going on with Monet and mosaic
I'm going to continue to do so like I
said if you haven't already check out
our other video on Monet really a
fascinating concept very ambitious goal
that they have but a worthwhile one and
I want to thank Monet for sponsoring
this video I'd love for our viewers to
go learn more about Monet read the white
paper see what they're all about and you
can use the link right underneath the
video to do that